sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur feierlichen
angelobung der rekruten die im juni 2020
eingerückt sind mein name ist peter beer
oberstleutnant peter bihn stingl
ich bin an der führungsunterstützung
schule und werde sie als moderator durch
die feierliche veranstaltung begleiten
die angelobung selbst die feierlichkeit
wird unter besonderen bedingungen
stattfinden
sie werden gleich die einrückenden
rekruten sehen sie tragen alle masken
solange sie eben den sicherheitsabstand
nicht einhalten können und wir werden
ganz gespannt sein für uns auch eine
premiere dass die aufstellung in den
reihen der rekruten dann entsprechend
mit sicherheitsabstand erfolgen werden
sie werden es zwischendurch immer wieder
die rekruten beim einmarsch sehen wir
befinden uns hier in der starnberger see
dem standort der führungsunterstützung
schule
die veranstaltung wird im namen des
streit der streitkräftebasis durch die
führungsunterstützung schule
veranstaltet und das besondere daran es
sind nur einige ehrengäste anwesend und
sehr viele teilnehmerinnen teilnehmer
werden dann über die internet
empfangsgeräte daran teilnehmen
wir haben hier das die herausbildung
funk stelle die uns sozusagen einen
livestream ins internet ermöglicht sie
sind live dabei bei dieser veranstaltung
sie sehen jetzt gerade die rekruten 115
rekruten mit dem bewegungs termin juni
2020 einmarschieren
die rekruten werden dann weit nach der
grundausbildung in den führungs
bereichen der streitkräftebasis ihren
dienst als cyber soldaten kraftfahrer
und sanitäter passé rechts vom redepult
hat auch schon das bläserquintett der
garde platz genommen
sie werden uns dann bei dem feierlichen
akt entsprechend begleiten
auch carola bedingt nur eine abordnung
ein quintett sonst eher solche
veranstaltungen eben durch die
militärmusik oder gar die musik im
begleitet
jetzt erfolgt die entsprechende
aufstellung und der chor ohne
bedingungen und die rekruten dürfen dann
auch die maske abnehmen sobald
entsprechende abstand eingehalten ist
während noch die aufstellung
perfektioniert wird die cyber soldaten
kraftfahrer und sanitäter sind
größtenteils schon mit wissen
vorbelastet insbesondere die cyber
soldaten haben einschlägige kompetenzen
und wurden eingehend auch ausgewählt
damit sie ihren dienst dann entsprechend
in den funktionen in den zukünftigen
funktionen während des grundwehrdienstes
erbringen können
sie kommen aus ganz österreich und
stehen im führungsbereich der
streitkräftebasis nach sechs wochen
grundausbildung zur verfügung
aktuell sind sie gerade im
grundwehrdienst in bruckneudorf und
lernen das militärische grund handwerk
um entsprechend als soldat gerüstet zu
sein
der kommandant der ausgerückten truppe
ist major clemens holzleitner er wird
dann die rekruten und die ähren der
information und die den fahrer top
entsprechend kommentieren
ich habe schon das kommando gehört des
leeren zuges der jetzt die nächsten
minuten einmarschieren wird
der ehrenzug marschiert nun ein gestellt
durch teilnehmer das kader an werte
ausbildungslehrgang was die zuseher
hinter dem internet empfangsgerät nicht
so wahrnehmen
wir haben hier gott sei dank einen
falschen wetterbericht bekommen das
wetter hier ist wunderschön scheint die
sonne es ist warm
der befürchtete regen ausgeblieben
ich werde vielleicht kurz den groben
programmablauf erläutern
es wird dann noch der fahrer trug der
führungsunterstützung schule
einmarschieren
es wird dann die meldung an den
militärischen höchst anwesenden erfolgen
mit dem abschreiten der front und der
flaggenparade es folgen einige
ansprachen und der höhepunkt wird dann
das sprechen das treuegelöbnis sein wo
die rekruten das treuegelöbnis
nachsprechen
es folgt die bundeshymne und dann die
beendigung der veranstaltung das zum
groben ablauf dieses festlichen akt
da kommen dann dass er zu gerichtet doch
seine leute aus und an zu glauben der
auf mein kommando
ich spreche sie an all stars ganze das
ganze recht wild
[Musik]
ist erfolgt nun der einmarsch des
fan-clubs der führungsunterstützung
schule presse
[Musik]
das ganze gerade militärischen festakt
beginnt jetzt mit der meldung an den
militärisch höchst anwesenden an den
herrn oberst christian wally dem schul
kommandanten durch den comandante
ausgerückten truppe major clemens
holzleitner anschließend erfolgt das
abschreiten der front und die platten
gerade recht
herr oberst meyerholz leiten haben
meldet die druck bei angetreten zur
feierlichen angelobung ja wohl mit
festakt beginnen
[Musik]
ausgabe 10
die wer das ganze parade zu fahren das
ganze jetzt größer wir müssen das ganze
[Musik]
ein
das ganze
ich begrüße im namen der
streitkräftebasis den militärisch höchst
anwesenden den kommandanten der
führungsunterstützung schule oberst
christian waldi ich begrüße den herrn
militärärzte kann dr harald trip
als zivil höchst anwesenden begrüßen wir
herzlich den herrn landtagsabgeordneten
magister marcus schober herzlich
willkommen auch der bezirksvorsteher von
bezirk favoriten herr markus franz
wir heißen auch dr gerhard labitzke von
den wiener netzen herzlich willkommen
wir stellen uns natürlich jetzt den
applaus hinter den internet
empfangsgeräten vor ist für uns ein
neues gefühl
leider können wir das nicht verstärken
aber ganz besonders begrüßen wir die
rekruten die hauptdarsteller die
rekruten des eindrucks termins juni 2020
hier an dem platz an der family truppen
schule an der führungsunterstützung
schule weiter dass alle teilnehmenden
kader angehörigen soldaten der die
streitkräftebasis und der
führungsunterstützung schule und
insbesondere es heißen wir willkommen
hinter den internet empfangsgeräten alle
eltern familienangehörigen bekannte
verwandte freunde der rekruten herzlich
willkommen bei dieser veranstaltung die
leider nur über ihre internet
empfangsgeräte wahrnehmen können
[Musik]
das war der coral world in london
gespielt vom bläserquintett der garde
es folgt nun die ansprache durch die
militär geistlichkeit herrn will der
ärzte kann dr harald trip ich darf
bieten
liebe kameraden die sie heute angelobt
werden lieber herr oberst liebe
vertreter aus dem politischen leben und
der öffentlichkeit liebe mitglieder des
kaders die sie in der ausbildung unserer
jüngsten soldaten verantwortung
übernommen haben und diese verantwortung
gut wahrgenommen haben in sehr kurzer
zeit sind sie nun seit einigen wochen
zum österreichischen bundesheer gekommen
und sie werden sich gefragt haben was
muss ich da alles neu über mich ergehen
lassen der eine oder der andere von
ihnen eine neue welt in diese ein
gedacht sind und dennoch ist es auch die
welt von menschen sie haben auch gemerkt
die welt von kameraden und vielleicht
haben sie sich die frage gestellt macht
der dienst den ich tagtäglich zu leisten
habe auch sinn und für wen macht dieser
dienst sind vielleicht haben sie auch
zeit in diesen monaten beim bundesheer
über ihr dasein nachzudenken und eine
dieser großen jahr soldatischen tugenden
ist es kameradschaftlich zu leben für
den anderen da zu sein
loyal zu sein dort sich auch einzusetzen
wo der andere eher schwächer ist als man
selbst eine hand zu reichen ein gutes
wort ein offenes ohr zu haben möge diese
zeit für sie eine gesegnete zeit in
diesem sinne seien
haben sie mut zur kameradschaft und so
möchte ich einen kurzen gedanken im
sinne eines gebetes vor der angelobung
sprechen sie leisten heute das gelöbnis
auf unser vaterland die republik
österreich
und hier ist es auch wichtig zu sagen
sie brauchen kraft und stärke und diese
stärke sollen sie auch von gott bekommen
und so beten wir gibt dass wir uns zum
dienst am frieden für unser land um
diese welt bekennen her dass die orte an
denen menschen für diesen dienst
ausgebildet werden unsere kasernen zu
orten werden auf denen wir lernen unsere
werte zu verteidigen
achtung der menschenwürde liebe zu
menschen schenkt uns den geist der
verantwortung für die sicherheit derer
die unseres schutzes bedürfen
lasst uns der opfer der kriege stets
gedenken den toten ehre und anerkennung
schenken verletzten unterstützung
gewähren den flüchtlingen und
obdachlosen beistehen
herr unser gott segne die jungen
menschen die heute feierlich geloben die
republik österreich im dienste des
bundesheeres zu schützen und sich für
den frieden hier und anderswo mit allen
kräften einzusetzen
das sägen und bewahrens der gott des
friedens und des lebens
ich glaube ich darf nun den militärisch
höchst anwesenden den kommandanten der
führungsunterstützung schule oberst
christian walliser ins rednerpult bieten
sehr geehrte fest und ehrengäste hohe
geistlichkeit liebe eltern
familienangehörige freunde und bekannten
unserer rekruten die mittels internet an
unserer veranstaltung nun mehr
teilnehmen
vor allem aber sie die rekruten des
einigungstermin juni 2020 darf ich auf
das herzlichste willkommen heißen zu
beginn dadurch aus einem videoclip aus
dem internet zitieren dass ich vor
kurzem gefunden habe
dort heißt es sinngemäß lieber gott
lösche das jahr 2020 aus dem computer
und setzte es neu auf es hat nämlich
einen virus der nicht so leicht zu
entfernen ist leider ist es mit einem
neu aufsetzen des jahres beim corolla
wir es nicht getan
es bedürfte großer anstrengungen in
allen bereichen auch unter inkaufnahme
massive wirtschaftliche einbußen und
eines zeitlich begrenzten herunter fans
unseres öffentlichen lebens das wir
jetzt zumindest wieder in einen
lebenswerten rhythmus zurückkehren
dürfen
von einem normalbetrieb sind wir aber
nach wie vor noch sehr weit entfernt
auch ihre angelobung steht leider im
zeichen dieser einschränkungen die sonst
anwesenden partner angehörige freunde
und familien unserer rekruten müssen die
veranstaltung aus dem virtuellen raum
des internets beobachten die dadurch
fehlende psychologische unterstützung
und persönliche teilnahme muss durch das
gefühl ausgeglichen werden dass trotz
geografischer entfernung die geistige
und emotionale verbindung weiterhin
aufrechterhalten bleibt
dabei hat dieses virus sogar etwas
zustande gebracht was zahlreiche
militärische krisen in der vergangenheit
nicht geschafft haben weder die ungarn
krise 6 956 noch die tschechen krise 68
aber auch nicht der zerfall jugoslawiens
1991 wurden von der politischen führung
als so gefährlich eingestuft dass es zu
einer teil mobilmachung gekommen ist
erst in der aktuellen corona krise
wurden teile der miliz mobil gemacht um
wesentliche unterstützungsleistungen für
die wirtschaft und einsätze im rahmen
eines sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatzes sicherstellen zu
können präsident john f kennedy sagte
einst in seiner antrittsrede
frag nicht was dein land für dich tun
kann fragt lieber was du für dein land
tun kannst diese doch sehr
polarisierenden worte haben schon viele
essays und zeitungsartikel geziert und
ich möchte auch jetzt hier keine
diskussion vom zaun brechen
vielmehr möchte ich ihnen mit diesen
worten auch meinen tank als staatsbürger
übermitteln dass sie mit ihrer
entscheidung zur ableistung eines
militärischen grundwehrdienstes einen
entscheidenden beitrag für die
sicherheit und den wohlstand in unserem
gemeinsamen haus österreichs leisten
sie werden nach ableistung der
sogenannten basisausbildung kern nach
verschiedene drucken körper aufgeteilt
werden wo sie in verschiedenen
funktionen ihren restlichen
grundwehrdienst ableisten werden diese
funktionen können tätigkeiten im bereich
der logistik als selber soldat aber auch
in diversen system erhalten aufgaben
beinhalten für alle funktionen aber gilt
sind niemals selbstzweck dienen einem
gemeinsamen ziel und können nur durch
kameradschaft teamarbeit und
solidarische anstrengung erfüllt werden
der endkämpfe
[Musik]
entsprechende kulisse aber fürs internet
hier her bestimmt
der einzelkämpfer marken action serien
eine heroische rolle übernehmen im
alltag des militärischen dienstes ziel
teamgeist und gegenseitige unterstützung
gerade in den vergangenen wochen wurden
sie manchmal an die grenzen ihrer
leistungsfähigkeit geführt und es wird
auch zukünftig noch die eine oder andere
aufgabe auf sie warten die sie nicht im
alleingang lösen werden können
in solchen momenten ist kameradschaft
durch die unterstützung ihrer kameraden
erforderlich sie meine herren rekruten
werden ausgebildet um auf die
zahlreichen bedrohungen militärische und
nicht militärisch art neudeutsch heißt
das hybrid ausgebildet und vorbereitet
zu sein
dies ist die aufgabe nimmt der
militärischen führung und das bundesheer
ist aufgabe der politik ist es die dafür
notwendigen finanziellen ressourcen
bereitzustellen und diesen bedrohungen
und herausforderungen auch entsprechend
begegnen zu können
und ich spreche hier nicht von oft
zitierten panzerangriff im weinviertel
ich spreche von bedrohungen wie einen
blackout einem selber angriffe auf
staatliche institutionen aber auch von
angriffen gegen kritische
infrastrukturen wie es kraftwerke
kommunikationseinrichtungen oder
flughäfen sind auch eine pandemie wurde
schon vor jahren als bedrohung für
unsere wertegemeinschaft erkannt
aufgezeigt und gemeldet unsere jungen
rekruten sind aber nur in der lage ihre
aufgaben für österreich zu erfüllen wenn
ihnen auch das erforderliche gerät die
notwendige infrastruktur aber auch eine
leistungsgerechte besoldung von seiten
der politik zugestanden wird
somit darf ich ihnen für ihre aufgaben
alles gute wünschen mich aber auch
nochmals für ihre entscheidung dem staat
zu dienen
aufrichtig danken bei ihnen den
angehörigen unsere anzüge lobenden
rekruten an den internet empfangsgeräten
möchte ich mich mit der bitte
verabschieden unsere jungen soldaten
tatkräftig zu unterstützen
sie leisten einen wertvollen beitrag für
unser haus österreich
ich liebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die streitkräftebasis es lebe
die führungsunterstützung schule
dankeschön
das bläserquintett der gerade wird nun
den traditionsmarsch der
führungsunterstützung schule spielen der
windisch kretschmer
[Musik]
ich biete nun den herren
landtagsabgeordneten magister markus
schupp an das rednerpult
sehr geehrter herr kommandant sehr
geehrter herr bezirksvorsteher hohe
geistlichkeit werte soldaten und
soldatinnen aber vor allem sie werte wie
gruppen in vertretung von bürgermeister
michael loth weg darf ich mich recht
herzlich bedanken dass sie sich für den
dienst beim österreichischen bundesheer
entschieden haben den tag der angelobung
den vergisst man nicht und ich muss
jetzt sagen das ist knapp 20 jahre her
und ich kann mich sehr gut daran
erinnern der hauptredner damals war der
landeshauptmann vom burgenland er hat
knapp eine stunde gesprochen das werde
ich heute nicht tun aber ich habe auch
einen kameraden hier der mit mir damals
dort war und wir können sehr gut an
diesen tag erinnern und auch daran
erinnern dass das stadion damals in
oberwart prall gefüllt war von menschen
von verwandten von lieben freunden und
das ist der unterschied zu ihrer
heutigen angelogen
ich hoffe sie können das mit ihren
eltern mit ihrer familie noch mal
nachholen und ich hoffe dass sehr viele
heute zu sehen und leider nicht hier
anwesend sein können persönlich freue
ich mich sehr hier sprechen zu dürfen
es ist unter anführungszeichen auch so
meine kaserne ich wurde hier zum
fernmelde office hier ausgebildet und
ich kann mich sehr gut in sie
hineinversetzen
ich bin sehr oft auf diesem platz
gestanden auch bei paraden und man
stellt sich als junger mensch natürlich
auch die frage warum stehe ich jetzt
hier was soll das ganze
und ich kann ihnen garantieren seit 1955
haben sich sehr viele diese frage
gestellt wir können aber sehr stolz
darauf sein dass sehr viele diese frage
auch beantwortet haben
nämlich mit taten die sie für die
republik österreich und das
österreichische bundesheer gesetzt haben
wir haben heute heuer mit 1955 auch
eingedenk ja dass wir nicht zu begehen
können wie wir es gerne begangen hätten
aber es ist so dass ab 1955 dieser junge
republik sehr schnell krisen zu
bewältigen hatte der kommandant weiter
hat er schon gesagt die ungarn krise die
tschechoslowakei krise die jugoslawien
krise
die flüchtlingskrise und viele viele
andere aufgaben es war auch diese junge
republik die sich relativ rasch
entschieden hat international für den
frieden tätig zu sein und so sind wir
schon den 60er jahren damals in einen
einsatz in den kongo gegangen und ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass dieser
einsatz dazu geführt hat dass wien heute
uno sitz ist und der einzige ohne sitz
in der europäischen union und das
verdanken wir auch dem engagement jener
soldaten und soldatinnen die diese
letzten jahrzehnte im einsatz für den
frieden sind es sind nämlich nahezu
immer 1000 soldaten und soldatinnen in
den unterschiedlichsten ländern mit dem
österreichischen bundesheer in diesen
friedenseinsätzen tätig sind und die
rückmeldungen die wir international
bekommen sind immer einmalig und sind
wir dass reporter report wort für die
reputation der republik österreich sehr
sehr wichtig sie haben jetzt ihre
grundausbildung hinter sich gebracht und
jeder der eine grundausbildung gemacht
hat weiß was das bedeutet
ob es weitere schon gesagt sie sind an
ihre grenzen gegangen
am besten zeigt man aus dieser zeit
keine bilder her aber sie haben eine
fundierte ausbildung bekommen und das
ist notwendig um ihren auftrag auch
erfüllen zu können
sie leisten einen wichtigen beitrag für
die republik österreich und das wird
auch in vielen reden gesagt die republik
österreich hat auch einen wichtigen
beitrag zu erzielen fühlen wenn es um
die finanzierung des österreichischen
bundesheers geht ist es egal welche
koalition und welche regierung
dementsprechend an der macht ist seit
jahrzehnten haben wir das problem dass
wir unterfinanziert sind und ich glaube
da muss sich etwas ändern
sie haben mitbekommen dass wir eine
teilmobilmachung des österreichischen
bundesheers der miliz gehabt haben und
hier möchte ich an dieser stelle
erwähnen dass alle dafür plädieren
müssen dass die kameraden und kann
erinnern einheitlich bezahlt werden weil
sonst werden wir zukünftig ein problem
bekommen was die motivation betrifft und
ich höre auch schon aus dem ministerium
dass da viel getan wird dass man
dementsprechend auch hier daten setzt
wenn es um die einsätze des
österreichischen bundesheers geht so
wird relativ rasch vergessen wenn ein
einsatz vorbei ist ich möchte noch in
der jüngeren vergangenheit einige
beispiele nennen 2015 in der
flüchtlingskrise war es so dass das
wiener militärkommando alleine über eine
million mahlzeiten für menschen auf der
flucht zur verfügung gestellt hat 2009
10 bei der aktion schnee soweit ich
weiss es geheißen sehr viele soldaten
und soldatinnen im einsatz waren die
direkt geholfen haben und auch jetzt in
der krise meistert österreichische
bundesheer
es waren die ersten die im einsatz waren
mit den abc einheiten und mit der
hercules die österreicher und österreich
erinnern wieder zurück in ihre heimat
gebracht haben erlauben sie mir auch ein
internationales thema anzusprechen wir
haben in den letzten wochen sehr viel
aus den vereinigten staaten gehört da
ist es so dass die polizei
berechtigterweise in diskussion ist es
ist aber so dass diese diskussion auch
nach europa nach österreich kommt und
das ist dann oft in diesem fall in
dieser frage uniformierte trifft es
macht beim österreichischen bundesheer
keiner unterschied woher er kommt wenn
einmal diese uniform trägt sie geloben
heute dass sie den schutz aller in
österreich österreich lebenden menschen
gewährleisten werden
gerade in dieser phase war er sichtlich
wie sehr berufs und milizsoldaten wenn
es wirklich ernst ist ihr engagement
zeigen und bereit sind für die republik
österreich tätig zu sein
ab dem heutigen tag gehören auch sie zu
dem kreis zu jenen die in
unterschiedlichen funktionen wahr sein
werden wenn man sie braucht
vielleicht sind einige fragen nun
geklärt warum sie hier sind ich darf das
vielleicht auch weiter denken für mich
für mich war es eine klare entscheidung
zum österreichischen bundesheer zu gehen
ein direkt freiwillig zu sein weil ich
einerseits für den schutz meiner familie
meiner verwandten meiner freunde unter
republik eingetreten bin
zum schutz unserer republik und
demokratie der liberalen
österreichischen demokratie und das sind
werte die es zu verteidigen gilt
ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn einer
von ihnen vielleicht auch berufssoldat
wird freue mich noch mehr events milizen
dort werden hauptsache sie engagieren
sich in österreich im bundesheer sie
haben auch dementsprechend eine zeit die
sinnvoll ist oder abschließen kann ich
ihnen sagen die stadt wien ist stolz auf
sie ist stolz darauf dass sie sich
entschieden haben und stellvertretend
für die stadt wien möchte ich mich
nochmals bei ihnen bedanken
sie sind der garant dafür dass wir
helfen können wo andere nicht mehr
helfen können
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es folgt nun der höhepunkt des
militärischen feierlichen aktes die
angelobung oder sprechen das
treuegelöbnis dazu wird der fahrer trug
vor treten zwei rekruten zu eingeteilt
werden stellvertretend für ihre
kameraden vortreten zum fan truppe und
anschließend wird das treuegelöbnis von
mir vorgesprochen und von den rekruten
nachgesprochen austreten
eigene hütte rekruten vortreten
mit guten sprechen sie mir nach ich
gelobe mein vaterland die republik
österreich
und sein volk zu schützen
und mit der waffe zu verteidigen ich
gelobe den gesetzen und gesetzmäßigen
behörden treue und gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit all meinen kräften der republik
österreich und dem österreichischen volk
zu dienen
fahne eintreten
[Applaus]
es erfolgt nun das abspielen der
bundeshymne und anschließend die meldung
an den militärisch höchst anwesenden
über die beendigung der veranstaltung
und mit der bitte um weitere befehle
[Musik]
wer das ganze gerade das ganze interesse
hier
zur meldung das ganze ja was man ja
holzlatten dann meldet die beendigung
der feierlichkeiten und bittet um
weitere befehle
jawohl einrücken
das ganze
wer das ganze gerade das ganze presse
zum auszug der fahne das ganze recht
[Musik]
wer das ganze gerade komponenten
übernehmen abrücken
während nun die truppenteile abrücken
und abtreten
darf ich mich noch einmal herzlich für
ihre teilnehmer teilnahme bedanken
insbesondere die teilnehmer teilnahme
hinter ihren internet empfangsgeräten
besonderen dank auch an alle durch jungs
verantwortlichen an die musik ihrer
information und insbesondere auch anders
hbf das uns jahres bildfunk stelle die
uns ermöglicht haben diese veranstaltung
live stream zu ihren geräten zu nach
hause zu übertragen
danke auch nochmals an alle rekruten
dass sie hier durch ihre meldung zum
österreichischen bundesheer wird sich an
gelungen lassen und wir wünschen ihnen
alles gute für die zukunft viel
gesundheit und ein schönes wochenende
danke